arguably the most natural and powerful
form of learning is through experience
or more precisely through reflection on
doing also called experiential learning
it's what prima ballerinas do after
their performance at the national opera
but it also happens to boys that are sad
because their father got angry when they
played football in the living room by
the age of one we all had our own
painful encounter with experiential
learning when we tried to walk failed
fell and cried like well a baby and even
though this was an unpleasant and
discouraging exercise that lasted for
months in the end we all made it how is
that possible as soon as we fell and the
first shock was over our brain
unconsciously began to make sense out of
all the information available to
identify how this embarrassment occurred
it remembers that when we pushed
ourselves up everything was fine
our feet on the floor our arms in
position and our head and shoulders
upright ready to go when our upper leg
muscles pulled our left foot 12.3% to
the front at an angle of 23 degrees our
arms didn't complement the movement and
the ventricles in the inner ear
responsible for static balance got
confused for a second one at the same
moment the cat ran by our eyes sent an
alarming signal to the hippocampus and
we completely lost it ouch
unconsciously this is how our brain
analyzes the relationship of events
within our body or in the environment it
happens all the time as we learn to walk
talk kiss function in a fancy office or
dance the salsa once we understand the
connections between what went wrong we
know what we need to change when we try
the next time experiential learning can
also be used explicitly to learn a new
skill or to become better at what we
already love doing here is how it works
first get yourself into a situation to
experience after reflect on what
happened then try to understand the
relationships to form an abstract
concept if I do a I get B last decide
what to do differently next time then do
it again experiential learning is also
believed to be responsible for the fact
that musicians generally fare better of
most tests regardless of what they
measure people that practice an
instrument not only engage their brain
in motor visual and auditory areas but
they also learn by reflecting on what
they're doing with a fast feedback loop
a wrong tone on the violin sounds too
terrible to remain unnoticed while
playing they therefore not only learn to
make music but also that progress in
general comes through practice
reflection understanding and repetition
you can use it with your friends or
colleagues when working on a project
Silicon Valley startups - it when they
tell their developers to get out of the
building after the interaction with real
potential customers the team gets
together analyzes the feedback and
decides what to do next
tell us what do you think is learning
through reflecting on doing only good
when acquiring new hands-on skills or is
it also suitable to study science math
the humanities or abstract art